salut et bienvenue dans cette vidéo avec
un nouveau casse tête les gars stage de
l'été ça continue aujourd'hui avec un
casting qui s'appelle n'eurent 4 parce
que quatre cases il va falloir faire les
numéros les chiffres de 1 à 4 dans
l'ordre 1 2 3 4
voilà vous savez tout merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo abonnez-vous au
revoir à personne n'a jamais fait cette
blague lui je trouve un peu en tension
c'est comme des vacances
ok aujourd'hui on va résoudre donc chez
lui si ça il faut enlever cette petite
protection la permettait juste que ça ne
glisse pas durant le transport et je lui
sur le petit papier qui étaient fournis
comme d'habitude je peux le répéter une
fois le casse-tête le lien est dans la
description il est également à gagner à
la fin sur mon instagram que si je le
réussis si je ne réussis pas ce sera la
vidéo je le réussis ray comme d'hab et
vous avez maintenant la version non
montée de tout ce qui va se passer si
vous préférez voir sans montage
attention ça peut durer jusqu'à trois
heures forcément sur machine secondaire
vous avez le lien de la description tout
est dit c'est parti loïc je veux des
plans de ce casse-tête badass maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok ben on est parti donc le système est
très simple à comprendre
on a quatre cases qui sont du coup a
movie passe quand on a la une qui a un
trou donc je pense qu'à trois épaisseurs
par case tient la place de plexi la
première la deuxième et ensuite le fond
que nous pouvons voir ici à qu'on peut
bouger aussi d'ailleurs en faisant ça et
donc l'idée c'est d'avoir les quatre
font partout et 1 2 3 4
en additionnant les trucs entre par
exemple deux là je cherche le pain et le
1 il ya rien d'additionner c'est celle
ci donc 1
il faut qu'il aille là bas il faut
surtout qu'ils soient tout seul là bas
déjà on va l'emmener là bas ne conseille
pas vu à temps là il peut hélas il
pourrait pas y aller a en plus ils
peuvent pas tous passer comme j'aimerais
lui passent et le débit passe pas je
vous explique le bail
ça ça passe là de la droite vers la
gauche ou pluie par exemple passe de 1
ne passe pas de temps mort bah c'est pas
possible à un [ __ ] il faut que j'élève
des fois un petit peu avec mon doigt
comme sage appuie un peu pour lever
d'accord il ya de la friction qui gêne
aussi c'est le 1
il faut qu'il aille
ici
ça c'est le cas mais il doit être tout
seul alors que lui ils doivent barrer
lui lui ça doit être celui de
je comprends pas je t'ai dit peut-être
du 2 mai dans le 2 je pense que c'est
lui c'est même sûr que ce soit lui mais
il a déjà un traité ici nous avons doit
être ça peut-être en levant est
important non c'est le 1 qui a fait
tomber mais lui est déjà un mort ça doit
être le système des plaques alors si je
fais comme ça l'a donc là si vous
comprenez pas ce que je vais faire
passer le fond qu'il ya là ici ainsi
celui sera celui 6 un mois et b et du
coup je vais pouvoir éjecter suis là ou
pas si voix la plage et trois plaques de
plexi et j'ai un fond du coup le 1 je
peux le mettre là oui je le descends n'a
lui je le descends là du coup là j'ai
une soupe et soeurs et je peux en être
ok j'ai mis le un solo pour l'instant ce
n'est pas si compliqué le 3 doit être à
sa place et le cateau 6 à sadec le haut
du dos ça veut dire que deux est à sa
place
ça veut dire qu'en france on est à
combien on est à cinq minutes et déjà
j'ai déjà fini le casse tête bien est-ce
que j'en commence un autre belge est
celui avec la pièce tu sais bon ben des
eaux
il était marqué comme étant difficile en
fait je pense que le truc tu étais
triqueti c'était les fonds et comme je
lé fais par hasard en retournant pour
vous faire voir j'ai trouvé tout de
suite dans la vraie vie jamais tu leur
tombe comme ça et voilà et ben écoute on
va essayer safe
ok c'est pas la même c'est que je le
gardais pendant très longtemps alors
save que je me fasse voilà comme ça est
très jolie
loïc petits plans badass de safe saïfi à
une pièce qui est ici de 1 euro il faut
la faire sortir par là voilà c'est ça le
prince il y a plusieurs couches vous
pouvez le voir il ya la couche ou et la
pièce qu'il ne bouge pas du tout je
crois que ça bouge pas il ya la couche
en plastique en dessous une couche en
bois en dessous et notre couche amovible
dans chacune des couches il ya un cercle
il va falloir faire passer la pièce de
cercle en cercle pour la sortir mais
pour bouger ces cercles ya comme un
petit labyrinthe à l'intérieur j'espère
que vous le voyez bien à la base on
voulait pas le faire tout de suite parce
que justement j'avais peur qu'on voit
mal en fait si j'ai bien compris voilà
je peux bouger c'est cesser ces éléments
là comme ça des éléments c'est les
espèces de petites vis comme ça
et en fait je vais les faire se déplacer
dans le labyrinthe n'en reste en flic si
si c'est pas bien clair ce que je suis
en train de dire je m'en rends bien
compte mais vous voyez l'idée donc là je
vois qu'il ya le cercle ici pour la
pièce donc l'idée serait plutôt de le
monter jusqu'à la pièce là je peux aller
jusqu ici
après ça bloque pourquoi
c'est à bloc à cause de lui donc c'est
lui qui me saoule quoi sa force là le
plastique ça va hélas en bois
c'est bon
maggie du coup le plastique je préfère
passer comme ça lui comme çà et là du
coup plastique je peux leur remontée oui
ce qui veut dire que je peux emmener la
pièce art butin par les bâtards
alalalala vous avez l'impression
là j'avais l'impression que le truc en
plastique allait arriver pile poil en
dessous
en fait il ya un truc qui bloque de ce
côté là [ __ ] c'est riquet à mort c'est
très malin de leur part parce que j'y
croyais mais vraiment j'y croyais
efforts quoi aux usa c'est bon la
première étape avait fait ok donc
pourquoi pas ce que parce que là il ya
unité en plastique
ok ça veut dire que là il aurait fallu
que ça inclut il faudrait que je
l'emmène parlera d'abord et je peux pas
je l'emmenais knife ou d'accueil la
baisse ménages peuvent pas du coup que
lui il faut que je ramène un peu le bout
des doigts de trouver devant lui pour le
bout de bois donc le plexi up
ce qu'il faut mais je l'amène dans le
130r comme ça écoutez ça c'est comme ça
pourquoi ce qui me gêne rien d'accord ah
[ __ ] il est tombé j'ai même pas fait
gaffe je suis trop con ripley s'il te
plaît loïc de caen ça la pièce est
tombée dedans en fait j'étais concentré
sur la vie est là je les ai pas vus
tomber là ok trop trop cool
du coup maintenant il faut que j'arrête
cette pièce d'un seront là en bois là
vous voyez et l'auront faudra que je
l'emmène après sur le rond inférieur
kate qui est ici est ce que le plus
simple serait passée par là où l'autre
côté moi je crois que je pense que ça va
être
il faut vraiment penser des deux côtés
ce très dur un schéma de pensée
il faut penser de deux côtés en même
temps tout en pensant aux épaisseurs
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est pas si
simple en fait
ok boom d'accord
ok en toute logique cette pièce si je
vais au plus court ce serait par là haut
mais par là auront bien le faire en fait
et on pouvait pas continuer bon je pense
qu'il faut refaire le tour par là mais
j'ai pas de possibilité de faire le tour
par là et non je crois que non en fait
j'ai annulé mon chemin pour rien
ce qui m'intéresse c'est que le bout de
bois il vers la droite et le plastique
vers la gauche
du coup je crois que c'est en train de
refaire exactement la première étape
si j'arrive à le remettre après bush
pourrait l'amener à droite ça c'est
plaisant donc c'est lui qui bloque le
bout de bois dans sa rotation comme ceux
ci et c'est lui qui bloque du plastique
dans sa rotation comme cela donc je vois
un compromis il ya un des deux qui doit
bouge pas c'est le serpent qui se mord
le pneu est survenu dans cette config là
en fait mais toi mon gars
mais t'es pas bien la remarque à temps
mais je le pousse et là je peux le
dévissé en fait comme lui il est en face
du trou qui a là je peux vraiment assez
facilement le dévissé et du coup je me
dis est ce que ça fait partie du casse
tête si je le vire là d'un coup c'est
vachement plus simple tu crois non c'est
pas possible c'est pas fait pour loïc ça
va être tout noir loïc c'est toi qui le
dit vas-y c'est rare
[Musique]
on ne dira rien un tout petit peu plus
mais pas assez quoi vous narguer un bug
est peut-être elle devrait quand même
tombé regardez la pièce et la côte à la
cardan commencé à tomber dedans
elle veut la pièce tombée elle demande
que ça oh oui il est tombé là j'ai passé
la deuxième strate les gars trop cool
deuxième strate passé donc maintenant il
faut que j'emmène l'ensemble ici je les
fais tout à l'heure par hasard mais là
j'ai tout mixé depuis donc mais il ya
moyen vraiment moyen de se le faire sur
mais [ __ ] faut prendre des vrais temps
de réflexion par contre faut pas jouer
les marrons chauds autour de lui et de
lui pour le mettre ici c'est plus pour
que je voulais faire ça mais je sais que
ça avait du sens dans ma tête
exactement pour cette raison là oh
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
loïc langlet mais qui sait mais qui
est-il ces castes et enter chasseurs des
casse tête
[Musique]
je n'ai chasse mais après j'ai remis en
liberté je les tue pas je peux vraiment
pour la chasse mon gars donc il est hors
de question de tuer un casse tête
j'ai pris énormément de plaisir à le
faire ce n'est pas si long très sympa du
coup je le referais je le remettrais
à 0 sur un petit live sur un
stationnement je ferai ça en bonus sur
instagram vous vous pouvez le gagner
ensuite une fois que j'aurai mis dans le
bon ordre avec la photo qui via ici
évidemment la version non montée de
cette résolution sur ma chaîne
secondaire tout les liens sont dans la
description y compris le lien pour
acheter le casse tête
à très bientôt je vous aime fort ciao